[Music]  to  whatever I do I do it to protect you  Princeton dressed of course we have  intercepted by coded Imperial  transmission it indicates that a major  weapons test is imminent we need to know  how to destroy it so why me the message  was sent by your father they call it the  desktop  you need to capture the gun if my father  built we need to find him if the Empire  has this kind of power what chance do we  have  rebellions are built on hope I want to  help we'll be the team  she wants to fight  there was a 97.6% chance of failure he  means well  it's some rogue wrote one may the force  be with us but we are dealing with his  immeasurable  we'll follow your lead you know used to  people sticking around and things go  back  take hold of this moment the force is  strong  please take the next chance  and the next until we win over chances  are spent  good I've been recruiting for the  rebellion for a long time  destroyed outside